it's Monday the 22nd of June
[ __ ] you and you cancel kick this
[ __ ] muley
[Music]
[Music]
one day
20 seconds and you're still locked up
and you gotta put your face mass on take
that [ __ ] - beautiful
[ __ ] they're to be alive
my guest is my brother long time [ __ ]
gangster Felipe Esparza what's up fool
former winner of Last Comic Standing and
all that [ __ ] now he's just back to
being an OG gangster on the road it's
good to have you back
the christ-killers here we're ready to
go for you [ __ ] that thought
you could hold this down it's over
listen the reason why I call my life
story on here
what's the two reasons to let you know
you could do whatever the [ __ ] you want
to do with your life it doesn't matter
if you have felonies addictions whatever
you get your life together to move
forward and it's to come clean and use
you guys a psychiatrist so somebody
wants to use the tape against me that
happened 22 years ago a tape that was
has been up for ten years how boring is
your [ __ ] life you know I'm saying
get yourself together I've made immense
and I've tried my hardest to be the man
my mother wanted me to be beside that I
don't know you [ __ ] nothin Oh
comedians or nothing so without that
that's it Felipe talk to me bad
[ __ ] what's up fool man know
what he's so glad to be here man
cancelled culture I'm sad bro
it's very sick I can't even get
cancelled I can't fool myself though
well I told I'm not even famous enough
to be canceled and if he and if they do
who gives a [ __ ] we're stand-up we're
not actors I'm not Jeremy Piven not
funny when it would be for Santa before
they were showing the video there I
remember I'm somebody's bad tweets came
up from eight years ago actually
Melissa Villasenor when she was about to
go on
it's the SNL some latina Chicana
socialist warrior woke Latin eggs lady
she says after about Melissa Villasenor
that she said you know she's a young
comic she wrote it she apologized but
she should've canceled her and I'm
trying to get her off sa now and I'm
like what so I tweeted myself you know
in her defense I remember I tweeted a
man if you ever try to go back to all my
tweets all you're gonna see is really
bad grammar
that's it from the beginning I guess III
you know people will call you on bad
spelling and a lot of people could spell
which is right so fast we write without
dinky like I don't proof check me
neither
something I forget something I say I'm
going over there I might not stay there
it just looks like I'm going somewhere
waiting I hate text messaging you ever
title guys
why did you see somebody and you look up
and it's the same boy it's his ball and
now they think you're saying something
wrong to some so I don't and I got no
glasses half the time neither the why I
don't even I got just disconnected the
thing what am I gonna get text message
for but people to bother me I don't need
to people bother me in Texas I can't see
it
and when I would send back I don't like
people texting me for business if you're
gonna want to do business you're gonna
call me what's been going on the worst
the worst be him hell yeah the worst
text you can ever get or first email
anywhere can I ask you a question you
just dated your [ __ ] get to the
question can I ask you a question
or will they text me can I ask you a
question or they call me and leave a
message
can I call you and ask you a question
you did take me one time bro that was
when I was not picking up my phone and
you were worried you said how many times
do I have to call you [ __ ]
haha that's true though man I've been
doing great man um I mean I'm staying
home I've been walking my dogs I've been
getting up early six o'clock in the
morning every day this is the first time
you've been home at 9:00 and I want
money man there's the first time I've
been at home and ever dude as long as
I've been without doing stand-up comedy
me as if you've been involved in common
21 years you imagine that after 20 years
showing of my time that's why I I
understand the pain people are in that
but when t years they had a day job and
now they gotta work out of the house or
not work at all this bothered me on
every level because people lost their
jobs just like we did we didn't [ __ ]
you know we're not better than anybody
else we lost our [ __ ] jobs we don't
know when that's coming back yeah they
doin comedy in Texas and Arizona and
Florida and jumping up and down
but the hospitals are filled up so
eventually they don't have to close them
they're gonna push these ones back say
you have to accept that we're gonna live
in a co-ed comedy culture and then I
never I when people say that I'm we're
on this we're all in this together then
you get the haters oh really you make a
million dollars a year or you make seven
million you make $85,000
I make thirty thousand how are we in
this together people don't understand
man that um people who make poor in
movies just say like for example Arnold
Schwarzenegger
he makes movies he's just saying movies
are in paramount paramount is clothes
okay those producers are still making
millions of dollars but there's two shoe
shine guys in ads walking around a
studio shoe shining shoes bro there's
still people out there making pizzas
there's a lot of people work in the
kitchen and Warner Brothers who are out
of a job so we in this together or not
and you know what let me tell you
something and you've been acting for a
while I've been acting for a while is
there any money in acting
hell no there's no money there's no
money in acting so when you really I
don't care how many times you see me
unhand if I'd on Netflix I only got paid
once what you know it's it's the
weirdest thing that there's no money in
[ __ ] acting no more to be honest it
made me feel not as bad about like not
being rich now because I can't imagine
having a $10,000 month mortgage or
having a Tesla that I have to pay off
when people wake up in the morning and
they say oh I want to be rich I wish I
was rich that's a horrible statement to
say I want you to say how can I work
myself to have money not that I want to
be rich people think that because being
rich they they what's the word i'm using
for they think of riches having no more
problems no more problems everything
baby you're you wake up you wake up and
your [ __ ] glass is broken on your car
it just happened okay
you go upstairs and part of you does the
math in your head what's it gonna cost
you I got a call in sick for work now
you just lost another 50 that that up at
the top and the first thing comes to
mind is if I was rich I wouldn't have
money
these problems guess what you're gonna
have 10 times more problems for years I
saw it I want to be rich I want to be
rich I wanna be rich and then I figured
out that being poor made me happy
because the best times I had in my life
we're hooking up with you on a Tuesday
night when you would tell me bro I got
your green burrito I fought for you bro
kitchen without green burrito with green
hot saute pork on top the kitchen would
be closed and the [ __ ] light was
still be on a little box with a burrito
it wasn't I did comedy when I preside
don't comment no there was no money I
knew that going in and I told myself
after four years there ain't no money my
first feature spot was 450 opening up
for Lauri kill Martin in Seattle
preacher spot there ain't no money
there's no plane ticket they didn't do
you know what to say
it was 450 do what you want to do you
stay in a box outside we don't give a
[ __ ] so I always knew there was no donut
but guess what there was there was
compassion when I went down at that
burrito would be waiting for me that
little green chile burrito my point is
that I couldn't imagine just being an
actor I know even when we were
performing at The Improv when we were
allowed to perform at The Improv in the
beginning it was thought they were only
given a $15 C night we never saw the
check good even we saw the check it was
a came out of taxes seven dollars how I
went there broad we tell you man I went
there for the for the shrimp fettuccine
and the sideb Red Dog
those shrimp were huge every Wed and and
they made sure that the comedian that
were performing only ate and I remember
what time Joe deal had his big plate and
he had Gavin and he had Josh all around
Josh wolf all around his plate it'll
come out [ __ ] if buddy Freeman
passed that is by right now he's gonna
take my plate away what's the Spanish
waiter Oh bad he's still there out of
there you give him 20 hours you watch
them go to work
yeah really skinny oh my family's been
there it's just 1997 they open bro his
and his and his motto is
Felipe allows them a lot of them that
Spanish [ __ ] I mean that's your circle
[ __ ]
and as a thing when I want you he comes
up to you and says lee-sia
almost ah yes I loved it and he comes
and brings you a menu and you feel like
you deserve to eat that no matter if you
go on the first in front of a black
audience if you're following Damon
Wayans all the way at the end for one
minute he takes your mind off a comedy
wait till he brings that bread to the
table and you haven't eaten since 3:30
in the afternoon and he brings butter
and then he'll go you want more bread
yeah you know this is what it's all
really man this is what comedy you see
the humanities
I will come into the improv kind of
[ __ ] up and I will see him Mike dude
he's like hunchback bro with five plates
yeah he one of those dudes do you know
that um that respects work like you know
like some people like when one's their
job is done
don't stand around and do nothing this
can find a little broom bro and start
sweeping a little corner or wiping a
little grief up the side you know
watching you and he's keeping an eye on
everything man he's really sharp and you
see him nah give him a big don't Joey
come on Joe mando whatever his name is I
give him a big hug the manager has also
been now for Tony so the marketer -
right yeah yeah they just had a thing
for my cousin goes on Monday like at
6:00 but the improv that family over
there that that guy is from Boulder so I
hit it off with him right away he's
still the manager there the kitchen
manager or manager that'll be a really
sad part about restaurants closing cuz
that when I was a server for years and
yeah a lot people look at as like a job
you skip over but you're right there's
some people who take like those jobs
very seriously and like they're amazing
and you know where they're getting
served and they make tons of money
because it's all just tons because they
don't treat anybody like anybody else
does when you have them you know you've
been getting taken care of you know
last night two nights ago I had the baby
we were going home my daughter the baby
she's not [ __ ] baby and I stopped a
yum yum donuts mmm and some late you
know people calling in the donut orders
I want to smack them this is how white
they are where I live they actually have
the Spanish lady and again do you know
how special she barely knows English and
I walk in that last week I walk in there
two weeks got my daughter got her a
doughnut and there she is on the phone
with somebody I'm not coffee
what do you mean cappuccino I do not
know cuppa getting the people again we
want to double mocha and then and then
you know they show up and this lady
doesn't speak English she just put cream
in your coffee what mocha
it's yum yum donuts what cappuccino are
you talking about well Frappuccino what
flat white there's no flat white and
[ __ ] yum yum donuts No so they got
around the phone talking to Spanish all
her in my glade and she's looking and
she's going no what about this this is
like no just glaze I'm dying
because they're white they don't know
that she don't even know what they're
talking about
mmm no sandwiches sandwiches and people
and all said I'm like home as soon as I
walk in she goes hold on please
and she put some on hold and she goes oh
my no no she'll come right over and take
care me let me tell you something that's
the difference I don't care about the
guy calling in the order I care about
the live guy he's more important to me
that's money right there I gotta deliver
food to this schmuck or a thousand
things could happen how to pay a driver
I get hit with a bolt of lightning the
money is right there so take care of me
you ever walk into a place and the guys
on the phone and you wait for five men
oh yeah right there that's in my whole
world that's fired you're fine or
whatever the ends of the phone when
you're there when they answer a personal
call all right why another order fire or
they're in a bad mood but but then but
they're smart they're
mood is doing it you've taken your order
something I feel I tell you listen [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] how your day is
going when you're what you're working
you [ __ ] give me a little smile and
everything to be back and take my order
and you know what and if you're if
you're nice to me little bit a man
people I see people here stop like they
just be yelled at but they may come back
with me and and they're really nice to
me brought to us at listen man [ __ ] that
guy bro you're better than this and I
give my little five or no ten bro
something like that or it was a mercy
man you smoke weed yeah all right man
there's a spot over here when they saw
the best [ __ ] if I go there f3 if you're
there at 3:00 you know we buy you
something whatever you know I want to
you got to realize one thing that these
people when people gonna get angry that
I said this yes we opened up too early a
lot of businesses have opened up too
early unless you know you don't know go
ask those businesses go sit outside
those businesses and see how much of a
change it's made that they've opened up
early hasn't made that much of a
difference
they're still only making anywhere from
100 to two to three to five hundred a
day which is 7080 percent less to what
they're making they opened up too early
there's no money there's not that much
money going around right now the average
American is enlightening cigars and
buying houses right now you know that
their goal from paycheck to paycheck to
get unemployment god bless them they're
getting this stimulus check you know I
don't even know how we got for this
conversation this reef is good
we're somewhat a little man what the
waiters you know missin underneath
bended money when I go least I always
thought that you know when these
restaurants open they havin a hard time
right now guys the weed store I go to
urban trees I love them to that best
weed store around they're having a lot
of time people are going down it it's
not cuz the weed ain't good young-ran
you can see the weed is on fire comes
with labels it's that the money ran out
Cinco DeMayo weekend May 6 is when
people realize what the [ __ ] was going
and guess what now they're about to pay
off what rent Jesus next week most
Americans are about to pay a fourth rent
with no paycheck how do you think the
overall Morales how do you think the
[ __ ] why do you think I come here you
Wednesday and [ __ ] Monday and
Wednesday because I know and I want them
to know them I was that person I'm there
with you our morale is down we got
nowhere to go at night we think this has
been [ __ ] fun and jokes from me I
have been going out every night since
1979 and now you want to come out with
cancer culture in the worst time of the
world well we're supposed to be loving
people we're supposed to you know all
lives matter black lives matter all
these movements you know what man let me
tell you what I then two people have
told me this this and I and I think
you're gonna tell me this - because I
know it what type of man you are
did you reef all in love with Lisa over
this period yeah have you reef all in
love with Lisa right now two things
happen either you [ __ ] wanna stab
your wife and they're gonna find her in
the trunk in about a month there's gonna
be a bunch of wise message we don't know
what happened she went the route she
never came back watch either you fell in
love with your wife again or you hate
that person you saw them for what they
are in my house
weary fell in love with ourselves our
family became stronger and guess what
happened this weekend over the weekend I
got it I got an email from Tammy pass
gotelli she goes I hope you saw what
happened over the weekend the church
family came out this isn't an Internet
group this is a state of mind this is a
family and I appreciate this is a church
it's a beautiful thing to see and I owe
you [ __ ] at all you are because
you know I've had more woman in that
chair that most podcasters do I pick up
ton of women in that [ __ ] chair and I
give him a voice and ask any of them if
any time they had to do anything and
there's been some woman I send that
chair that had been pretty loose women
ask him ask him if they [ __ ] anything
has happened here whatever so before you
you know you once that dude got in
trouble with that [ __ ]
the guy who were the judge for choking
the girl in college at Cavanaugh I knew
when Cavanaugh when Cavanaugh got called
out by something he did 29 ago the
Supreme Court I set the clock I swear to
my mother the only thing it for years I
set the clock I go when is this gonna
end because somebody's gonna have to
find one of these videos one day the
problem they have is then I don't give a
[ __ ] they don't cancel me i cancel them
I'm saying the truth about my life
whether you accept it how come three
years
Felipe four years I read little things
Joe Diaz Alya Joe Diaz the line of those
stories are full of [ __ ] how come that
story wasn't full of [ __ ] you know and
if I'm such a bad person you worried
about a girl that suck my dick 22 years
or how about the guy I put in the trunk
of the car you never said nothing about
that you never brought that up or ever
it's or or what were they saying all
this time when instead it wasn't a it
wasn't a life that didn't state didn't
even another year every time they say
you're alive bro that didn't happen 1983
that didn't happen 1979 or how about
this
oh now thinking about everything I was
going down with you and the only thing
that I ever felt bad
every when you had the show if Alicia
Michaels and you stole that transgender
persons wig yeah and they're very
expensive wings yes and you felt bad for
it yes good later on you got your ass
kicked oh I feel terrible about that you
wouldn't you cannot be responsible you
are responsible for what you did when
you're 18 I'm not gonna always
responsible unless you rape somebody and
kill somebody like that again you don't
know what you're doing when you're 18
you saw a movie whatever I'm not gonna
send you money in prison because you're
in your own [ __ ] personal hell but
I'm talking about if you hit somebody in
the head with a bottle when you're 18
and now we're 50 that person lived you
live everybody live everybody live till
you don't keep hitting people in the
head with bottles well cool and my book
were cool I've done things I've done one
thing it didn't feel right and I moved
you know I love women I was raised to
love women
I was raised to love I love women shall
all shapes all sizes some I had fun with
some I didn't have fun with but none of
them ever could complain that is
something that didn't say I'm like I'm
not a I'm not a criminal I'm not a
sexual deviant if you call me a criminal
that I am if you call me out and say
thirty years ago I robbed your purse
oh [ __ ] yeah that probably happened I
probably did rob your purse this little
market cuz you turn your back you
wouldn't ask for fun you want to ask for
coke cuts and left your purse open look
at [ __ ] I got a robbery and left the
wallet sticking out
I got a robbed because you're a dumb
[ __ ] you know do I regret it Oh with all
my [ __ ] heart I was a stupid kid
that's what your dirties are for so get
it together the [ __ ] is wrong with these
people Felipe what the [ __ ] is wrong
with these people
and in the world of Hollywood if you
really knew Hollywood and you really
knew what type of people were out there
and you really see in it how many times
have you seen a famous manager go up to
the store how many woman are gonna suck
his dick they all run into him you can't
believe it guys to Richard when I went a
hot asian watch into the room even even
a young male comedian stop wearing
skirts they start saying let's not walk
it up to here can i how are you right
can I get you a drink
cinema drink we'll see that our women do
that though no not everyone does it but
the part that bothers me is everyone
pretends when they're getting angry
about this stuff that they've lived a
perfect life okay
I didn't say I didn't say anything on
Twitter I try to because when all this
stuff happens I'm like it's gonna be
over in a day or two but it's like the
booth I learned from a kid you don't
throw stones in glass houses everyone
has something everybody has something
that that and you forget you're very
high and mighty to be like oh he's a
terrible part like really like this was
so long ago you're saying that you can't
that yeah I would want to have the
ability to explain myself we're gonna be
like oh I'm sorry that I did that
that was ten years ago like that that
was 20 years ago we said it 10 years ago
I have a daughter now I have all these
women that I work with on a daily basis
yeah I wouldn't like myself that then
either but that's not who I am now
that's like that's like watching a movie
from a hundred years ago it's very very
separate don't be spooky we took her to
Texas how comfy spooky spooky or [ __ ]
live and die for me yeah you know I've
had contact with all the Deborah Hobbs
there's another [ __ ] Savage
I've had contact with all these women
and you [ __ ] sit there and go what
the [ __ ] so for somebody to say that you
have to know the Comedy Store in 1997
you have to know comedy and you have to
know the inner workings there's no child
molestation in comedy you know I mean
let me tell how bad Society is what
makes you wake up on a Monday morning as
a 20 year old girl and go today's the
day I'm gonna write that Chris D'Elia
whatever sent me a picture or whatever I
don't know what the exact story is this
happened four years ago am i sticking up
for the LIA yes and I am no I am if he's
a pedophile you know whatever but I know
crystal you not to do this he got a
bunch of women he dated a bunch of women
all those letters that came in on from
16 year old definitely jilted women you
know every time he showed up at the
store he had to brunch with I saw it I
saw a limp sitting next to me and
Mitzi's seat they were all [ __ ]
overage women that were able and willing
you know what that means they were able
and winning a couple years weeks ago Rae
dawn Chong came up and [ __ ] she [ __ ]
my jag when she was 16 she wasn't mad
about it she said I got what was coming
to me I wanted it you know half of those
girls on that Sunset Strip I've never
I've never been involved in a situation
like that I didn't like young girls when
I was 18 when I was 18 I didn't like
eighteen year olds they talk too much
that's why when I was 19 I did it to a
nine-year-old for [ __ ] eight months
in Colorado I real Daniel chicks
really twenty-eight-year-old that work
another 16 the first girl made out with
Matthew was 23 yeah I didn't write young
girl the single mom bro they talk too
much when you [ __ ] them they started
crying or the fridge you haven't walk
them home and rub their back I don't
know what I don't want that [ __ ] I don't
need that my life I gotta talk to them
now all the time every time the period
was late I got a call [ __ ]
complaining [ __ ] that all the women give
me a woman that's been brokenhearted
that's been cheated on and she knows
exactly where member ladies when you're
21 when you're 18 you have this dream or
this man you're gonna meet and then you
go out there and you meet a bunch of
[ __ ] much and by the time you're 28
you meet a guy that you know what you
never thought you would marry but after
what you've been through he's a nice
enough guy he's got a nice family and
he's got a job he's not gonna beat you
he's gonna be okay the guy you dreamed
about 18 and the guy you married at 28
and two different [ __ ] guys and it
shouldn't be the guy that's closest to
what your dad is you're gonna matter
without seeing it you're gonna see it he
is [ __ ] later I know man more young
women marry their [ __ ] death people
are like they felt like it let me save
me like I will watch movies and I'll say
like okay I think kind of chick I wanna
cuz that's one you see in a movie you
know that the one that Tom Cruise took
or you want the I'm gonna save it for a
girl you know you want a guy like Tom
Cruise you know but every once in a
while
man you gotta set up for a couple of
Luis Guzman say yeah I'm gonna set up
for a couple of Phillippe as far as us a
couple of Butch Escobar's you know Bush
is good bro I hear he Bush Escobar's put
up an awesome tweet with an awesome
Facebook post the first time with
epidemic and he put himself up there you
know where he stands in comedy you know
what this comment Roseanne and lead to
cut off or you and I were talking man if
you were doing concerts before anything
gonna happen ain't gonna so he's gonna
put that you know if you're doing if
you're doing comedy clubs headlining you
know your rooms are gonna be smaller if
you were doing one-nighters what the
[ __ ]
doing that was that was pretty much his
post it's crazy it's crazy because if
you were doing like corporate gigs
there's no more corporate gigs nobody's
gonna put other corporate people
together everybody that works together
in a factory for one comic I believe did
you see what happened Hartley's gainst
either after what's going on with all
these comics it's gonna be hard to book
another commentator College what
happened with the Philadelphia Phillies
no no did you see what happened in
training camp in Orlando right
wherever that point no no no Major
League Baseball in spring training
spring training but yeah that's not
gonna be good either Felipe in my heart
I feel a couple things I feel Colvin is
real you know I hope that it's watered
down guys my age don't get [ __ ]
murdered
I believe I'm wearing a mask I believe
in all that stuff but I also believe in
some I believe that once you put eight
people together something different
happens oh yeah I don't know why I know
four people were in a room and three of
them died in New York Michael yo
Geoffrey Julian and Lisa lampanelli's
ex-husband Frankie big balls whatever
his name is the keys ooh great guy I
just forget his name right off to be the
big balls whatever so it's proven you
get in a room like us but that's why I
don't want that's why I'm your writer
you have to put down I only want to deal
with one person when you go to Houston
and Dallas okay you want to deal with
one person the guy that picks you up at
the airport cars gotta be sanitized by a
little Lysol can so you spray in this
[ __ ] face oh we do they get the hint
and no more five people knocking on your
door hey Felipe good to have you here hi
Philippe oh my God we're so happy to
have you here how has it been yeah well
me and Lisa hi I'm your waitress here's
your menu if you need something let me
get it to you okay so what were you
saying
[Music]
I'm a young comic Mike I'm gonna do PI
men I'm Mike the emcee I wanted to know
how much time you were gonna go up front
I don't know about 4045 okay thank you
so I what were you saying Felipe hey uh
my name is Don I want to know how much
what music do you want to come up to
that seven people you already had
contact with so I want to cut that out
they're gonna have one covered please
get you everything you get the menu
email to you you call The Improv and say
I want the this before the second show
this dis this you know I need for them
right now anybody knows that works in
the offices we were talking about the
other day and we talked about it here
the amount and if you work in an office
after certain amount of floors they
treat it a certain way so they're
telling you to cover your computers and
with your paperwork away because now I'm
the guidelines you have to spray offices
with a certain chemical and it's got to
be clear for 20 minutes to kill all the
air and comedy clubs got to do that in
between shows you can't have 275 people
in there put them on put a fresh 275
people in can't do it I'm gonna work
that seat they're not gonna come to my
shows that's why I'm only gonna do
single shows at night I'm starting out
with single shows I cannot [ __ ] do no
shows yeah why I'm an old man I don't
wish I don't want to risk my audience
and why so I'll just do Brea and I start
until we figure out what we're doing and
then when I come into a comic about um
the same for the first weekend I just
want to do the Early Show I'm an old man
I don't want to be responsible for a
second show you want to put the second
showing in if they have to do a plane's
supposed to do when you get off a plane
I don't give I don't care if the flights
the way I want a guy in there with a
hazmat suit spraying everything down
it'll make me feel better
don't make everybody feel better I'm not
saying I still can't get coal bit
because one of the guys I'm flying with
can't have coal but I'm the plan so but
I want to lower my percentages and
is all your doing in this time period is
lowering your percentages of getting it
don't go to a supermarket at three 200
people or anyone in there go at 8 when
it opens you're the first one in there
breathing
there's not even whines anymore
supermarkets people running out of money
yeah
supermarkets are empty the days of lines
are over with food bank lines are
getting an old banger yeah cuz there's
no money a big lever a big lines so you
know we're gonna have a hard time for a
while I don't mean to scare people but
that's why you know I understand what's
going on out there I understand the
heartbeat of why somebody would look at
a tape from 10 years ago and say oh I
gotta put this up today I'm fighting for
what I equal rights I thought it was
black lives matter we were still talking
about black lives matter last weekend
what happened how'd you switch flavors
so you went you went after the lis on
Monday somebody else on Tuesday or Danny
Masterson which he deserved yeah we saw
that Scientologist I told you to sign
the 70 so right that's why the
Scientologists were quiet remember I
said to you on this podcast we was right
I said to you I said everybody's raised
their hand except to Scientology yeah
then I'm donating to black lies man
they're not doing nothing that's why
they were quiet because they were eight
and ready for their [ __ ] head Martian
to get arrested Danny [ __ ] Martian ed
whatever his [ __ ] name is Danny
Masterson Danny Masterson and if you saw
our boy Chris D'Elia mugged on my door
Chris D'Elia got he stayed trending even
after Danny Masterson and Danny
Masterson raped three women why
Scientologists have that [ __ ] down they
made the call they paid the envelope
probably he got out in 30 minutes Danny
Masterson they put up a three hundred
three hundred thirty they put up with
his bail was three point three million
they put up three hundred thousand
dollars that's nothing to them that
somebody's backyard
that's Travolta's backyard Wow
Travolta's I kind of want to put the
money out I've had five horrible movies
out in a row we'll tell them about the
masseuse in Europe how big
yeah that's how Scientologists get you
but I knew the Scientology's have been
too quiet for too long where's Isis an
Isis terror they just fall apart that
pimping I just read an article on the
sun'll underage girls in Mexico and
[ __ ] cube or something like that I
swear to god Isis yeah the kid the
kidnapping women in and selling them now
is when you destroy America I said this
four weeks ago they were showed up at
that rally in Hollywood last week in
front of Mann's Chinese Dena one guy on
top of another guy shoulders with bombs
on him and they both go jihad with a big
trench coat and they pull the [ __ ]
thing hold on one second
it's my man Nick Turturro on the podcast
live with Felipe Esparza
and the [ __ ] what's up for
what's up dawg
nothing they tried to take me down but
they couldn't the church family [ __ ]
stood up and told them all to suck my
dick that's how we do it dawg sour a
bunch of people some communist let me
call you when I get out of here I love
you
I'm good I'm good they can all suck my
dick and call me shorty stay black we
want a roll over I can't roll over you
know people got mad at me for [ __ ]
putting Ariane 22 years you're my
brother you're my brothers too late we
already it's too late if you go down I
go down with you and if I go down I
don't know what you want to do I'm happy
you came on the podcast day because that
proves to people how we stand together
we ain't [ __ ] around here no I ain't
no comment from saying I live that said
something wrong on a podcast four years
ago you know I got a bully me dog
not now you're not gonna believe me you
could have believed me fifteen years ago
but now you're in no danger
we got what's called freedom I'm gonna
point my life where there's nothing to
cancel what are you gonna cancel my
phone bill what are you gonna cancel
right I mean we're done for 16 years now
even pay to go [ __ ] themselves I'm loyal
16 years I've been with sprint 2000
[ __ ] for I got the phone service
before Dodger game with my check from
spider-man 2
well I got my check from spider-man 2 I
got a phone I went to the [ __ ] place
where they give you prime rib in
Hollywood that's well-known Musso and
Frank's mo some friends of my wife I
took two friends
we ate the pot roast or the boob thing
with the check that was the biggest
check I ever saw in my life for
spider-man 2 when I did it was 14 days I
dipped a ton of [ __ ] prime ribbon on
the horseradish and then from there we
went up to Dodger Stadium and i sat
there minding my own business and there
was a father and a son in front of me
you know the seats are staggered so you
don't sit behind somebody you're
staggered yeah Sam so I'm sitting like
this and my legs open and I feel a
little rumbling in my star row and I
feel that horseradish and that [ __ ]
horse meat they sell you and Musso and
Frank's getting all put together and all
sudden Philippe I started farting but
they were perfect they were ricocheting
off the chair and they were going in
between the father and son team right
and then it would spread like the
coronavirus like a fog and it would
surround it would surround their heads
the people I was sitting with couldn't
take it they were covering their faces
this father and son team would just sit
there and after about three minutes and
just oh just a nail in this fart the
father-and-son team would just look at
each other and then they would look back
at the cow by the looks of everything
the kid had a glove he was a little
idiot kids they thought he was gonna
catch a ball but too bad was sitting up
with the Puerto Ricans [ __ ] [ __ ]
hidden Sammy Sosa could in a ball up
there you were up there where the
[ __ ] buses don't run we went to a
Dodger game with somebody good and those
willing to take a sad Felipe open the
top
you know top thing young guys nothing up
there but a company or you gonna catch
his [ __ ] Korres cousin it's full of
it the top you know I don't know you
paint you the top of the top I think a
Dodger Stadium when there's a lot of
people in it's hot and again it's the
right price to 8 o'clock just a [ __ ]
little mosquitos bro and you got to take
the elevator up with 20 people that got
cold with that third floor never again
so [ __ ] all you can eat section I
don't know nothing about that a little
sensation so I don't be with a backpack
it's a hard time so I [ __ ] I'm
sitting there and I'm blowing every 20
I'm blown while these [ __ ] horrible
or spray trying to get rid of the ladies
have no I'm just having fun at this
point and the people I'm with the people
behind them the people I'm with the
three I was with my wife and two friends
and they're like Jesus Christ Joey but
the two people in front of me the
father-and-son team
Felipe every time they fought it they
would tighten up I wouldn't maybe there
was silent they weren't making noises
they just stunk horribly and they send
the wind was blowing mildly so they just
surround you even been smoking weed
outside and this was the smoke goes
around you the fart was going around
them they couldn't take it no more and
every time they kept looking at each
other finally the kids glove went down
and about the six thing it started to
one inning and finally the father of its
own each other and they just got up and
walked away bro they left the game they
couldn't think you should be canceled
for your farts your parts are pretty
terrible oh my god well Knievel tourist
man he farted in New York City but after
our show they went to this club with
Luis Guzman and Toby Hicks and they were
just at this nightclub and they were had
a tight little Club you know hot and
rodrigo farted loud but nobody heard you
because i proper proper right dude it
smells so bad
it cleared the whole club talk you hear
puerto rican going on yo the [ __ ]
gail gail alone answer corn yo bro the
photos moodle where cook the garlic
pills I take will put your different
planet listen to me I had an n95 mask on
the park at the beginning of this with
my daughter and one day I farted when I
was sitting there and I smelled it
through the mask I didn't know if the
mask was cheap or if my [ __ ] was that
good
you never say like you're sitting there
going I don't know what's what I don't
know if the mask is a Fugazi or my
[ __ ] [ __ ] is that much stronger
I don't know we talked about this but
that no idea yeah but I've been like the
worst parts are the one where you're
like been partying for three nights
straight you've been wearing the same
[ __ ] socks and I remember coming home
you know one of the night that you were
just calling me constantly and you know
I was [ __ ] up and I was not returning
your call and then he left you would
leave angry messages encouraging mess
and you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're better than this you know you
gotta be smarter than the white guys you
gotta be funnier than the black guys you
gotta stay focused everybody was just
everybody wants to see you go down so
man I remember man my stomach was
hurting real bad cuz I had a tower
[ __ ] burrito and she had a modest it
was like a [ __ ] I'll past old burrito
with a lot of sad stuff and I went to
sleep I changed toward Chavez I had
nothing in my body but that food I turn
on the fan real loud what we roll out
real high and now I fell asleep and man
I was farting in my sleep but the [ __ ]
was throwing everything in my face so I
thought I was dreaming brother I [ __ ]
there's someone threw me in a septic
tank well I love that
but this thing here of my father's I
love it but remember Joey farts a mile
ago I have to puke his beef is strong I
don't [ __ ] around this should be
canceled for that fart do what he just
said man put Dodger Stadium that was we
should have casted you from being in
left field pavilion
he's gotten better at too many angles it
every always been very good since high
school I know how to bank shot a fart I
can tell now we're gonna charge this
chair like 90 degrees but I'm also best
over I've done I've done the chai bomber
in front of you I don't override do
stretches I've been [ __ ] Eddie
stretch kid me stretch fart on you
because I got the I think I learned it
from the Chinese did you say what that
you [ __ ] everybody up the YMCA when
you were doing Pilates
I [ __ ] people up at the YMCA one time
I [ __ ] people up the biggest fuck-up I
ever had was on a bus lie school on the
way back from a basketball games
I blew two three farts that the world
whatever the worst things you ever smelt
in your life and when I saw the Chili's
crying was all I knew I had when the
cheerleaders were crying they're like
please whoever's doing this stop this is
terrible when I saw those girls crying
and I still remember the girl that was
crying at my farts and they was Laurie
Rosa I think that's her name she got
like the butch Patrick and do I still
remember her and another bunch of butch
Patrick proudest things are proud
cheerleaders cried I will welcome I was
having sex you know when I wire it out
and um oh you know you get real nasty
bro it's dark you're doing like you're
doing bad stuff and I was this girl
farther in my face when I was out there
but out but you know man you could
either ignore it or keep going bro so I
ignored it wouldn't with my mouth bro
like I'm like my mom with a bomb bro and
then later on she looks at me all pissed
off good look well you're mad and I made
a joke about it cuz you ain't my
cheesecake how do you know did you know
you farted cheese king of my mouth when
you when you when you having sex in
whatever you I know when I was young I
should date a girl early on and she
would she would have [ __ ] fought when
you were she orgasms as whatever they
call it
she was fought a little bit she please
she looked embarrassed
we only messed around Sheila queefer
lady Tiffany Haddish yeah she did on
stage bro
but we from your woman quit from their
[ __ ] though right yeah no this girl
farted I guess she got overexcited and
she would say I'm sorry and you would
feel badly you want it I love her look
cute well that little cute one
that's the first girl I think they'll
take the second a third girl they ever
messed around with like I ever really
messed around with she I can't say I was
probably 18 19 maybe what do you think
about totally pay you think you what do
you want to do what if they cancel these
two Houston tours Wow I pad I mean I
mean if they cancel these two shows I'm
good with that man we'll see but I'm all
my shows right now are being pushed to
2021 and then I don't have a tour set up
or nothing I do have a special that's
gonna come out I got I lucked out I was
telling me before you got here that yeah
I got to shoot my special the day after
Kobe Bryant died cuz he died on Sunday
and we shot my special on Monday and
this 26 yeah
the 2016 20 mm it was man people were
still sad at my show that day and then
we could we don't have rights for for
memorabilia so we had to tell some
people at the door you can't wear the
Laker jersey because it can't be
on-screen I know he died and then we
would have to go to his car and put on
another shirt
we shot two special the first one was in
the spat English and the second one is
Spanish you're the first coming on
Netflix to shoot a Spanish special
congratulations bro yeah man and how
where was this at we shot it at the I
don't know the the old galaxy theater
okay I think it's called something else
right now it's called the Science Center
no it's the observatory I don't know in
orange right yeah that was the old
galaxy that we still yeah me yet it was
slider was this the place where I used
to serve food yeah like it was a dinner
theater it was yeah it was the guy that
the same guy named Clyde he will book
the galaxy theater and he will book the
coach-house in San Juan Capistrano yes
Santa Barbara the galaxy was by the
Irvine improv yeah around that
neighborhood Santa Ana Santa Ana and it
was it's called the absorber Tory now
and it used to be like this is 97 yeah
man this is 97 98 we're talking about
hundred bucks 100 bucks Thursday night
there was like a piano guy there was
like a comedian layer and I remember
that I did comedy with a guy that was
one of the most interesting comics I
ever seen somebody told me that one
before I went down there somebody called
me and they said the guy you're working
with tonight was gonna be a star but the
angles didn't it just right he became a
star there wasn't as many options as
there are today and when I worked at
this guy forget what his name is I
forget whatever happened to him he blew
me away like that was the first guy like
I was already in LA I was already
watching Wendy Liebman
Irvine yeah I thought you so much Jeff
Jenna no this was that that particular
era the galaxy yeah the first time I
ever played the GAO's II I worked with a
comic that had been a legend he just
didn't do TV breakthrough no drug habit
no nothing he was like a family guy and
at the end he played the guitar and they
got a standing ovation and I opened for
him and I remember somebody called me
and said you're opening up precise
insights tonight he's an old-time but
he's been around a long time with
Tennyson those guys but he always kept
it low-key
his wife was something big so he didn't
want to travel but wait till you see him
he's one a little type of killers so I
remember I was driving to st. Anna and
mr. 405 22 so it's a four or five South
yeah for Vice okay I was not good
friends of him yet me and him had
exchanged hellos for about six months
okay
he had you know he had acknowledged me a
few times or whatever and one night
I you have to go to 101 north to the
four or five South right and I got on
the 101 north I was living in Hollywood
and I'm on the comm on the 101 north
when I pull him off with a bumper and
who do I pull up next we have we were
not good friends at this time at all and
I just happen to look to my left and it
was Joe Rogan in his Supra he was coming
from taping news radio rehearsing for
news rainy on Thursday night I'll never
forget that I pulled up and I looked and
it was Joe and I beep the horn I thought
he was trying to ignore me ain't lowered
his window he goes what's up bro
where you headed and I go to galaxy be
there to do comic was where's that like
oh I don't know I had that's when you
had the book
yeah the Thomas guide Thomas guy I go I
don't know I'm going to his gig he had
the super with the red rims
he was already [ __ ] killing it young
tons of hair and he goes will you be at
the store tonight and I go yeah I'm
gonna go down there and then come back
and go to the store and he goes wow
you're gonna do two spots tonight you're
driving an hour each way and I go yeah
it ain't [ __ ] we would just talk him
bumper-to-bumper and when I raised my
window that's the first time I think he
realized that I was serious about what I
was doing and after that we became
friendly that was the first real we were
friends from the story hey I yelled good
to see I didn't know what Newsradio was
and I was too scared to ask anybody cuz
I thought they'd think I was a [ __ ] oh
well I met John I thought Joe worked on
a show that did the news on the radio
please don't ever repeat that to nobody
I thought Joe Rogan was like Joe what do
you have to say well it's gonna be sunny
out there today with a touch of haze and
that that's what I thought Joe did so I
didn't really know and then maybe two
weeks after that I go hey bro do you
mind if I come to a taping of one of
your shows he's like yeah call this
number and I call that number and let
the message they call me right back
a ticket to go see me and I went down
there the audience like everybody else
and I watch and I was blown away it's
always cool man when tonight when you
meet a cool dude
you know cool comic like that meeting
with Joe Rogan and then you don't know
him that well I mean and then he he just
saw Joey's Drive
I remember man when I was at the Laugh
Factory I had just got off the stage and
Shawn Wayans the one of the way and
brotherly just tapped me a real night
the whole family beautiful bro every
time the wind see each other
you always give each other a hug and a
kiss like I brought like real brothers
you can see that too much you know so I
said oh he said what's your you're funny
what's your name
I said Felipe and I said I'm really what
else you do it just do this I'm trying
to get like writing jobs I'll I dog
I just I'm trying to get writing jobs
and then he goes um all right my brother
has the show on at night to the Keenen
Ivory Wayans show you want to write you
go hook you up and I said sure so here's
my number I give my number on Monday
morning
somebody told me um somebody calls me up
hey Felipe Esparza um you're gonna be
writing jokes I want you to submit at
least 25 jokes and fax them to me you
have a fax machine and I lied again I
said yeah bro I went to go look for a
fax machine with Joey Medina and it's
Sears bro an old one and I found it and
I [ __ ] I got a like a word processor a
cheap one too and they will call me
every day and I will write jokes every
day 25 and facts though and I thought
that though the coolest thing I only saw
one they I never got paid though but
that was cool man I mean that meeting
right there was Joe he man he hooked you
up like that and then I never forget
that shot and she hooked it up Wayne's
have always always all good
they're the best people ever else to get
some strain here I don't know their
names
Marlon Shawn Keenan and the younger well
I know the one from that did the more
were Bruce Willis
that's mark that sounds damon wayans ami
wins a nice guy damon wayans is you know
I'm gonna reach out to him you know what
I reached out to guys Petros no way yeah
he lives in Studio City
Piero's what up yeah I wanna rent a
podcast yeah that's my man
it's time for him to go into the whole
thing he brought the record of home hits
1492 from Ty Cobb no but people just
don't get it no more we talked about the
next day it was trending because they're
talking about how they the Houston
people or the people in the Yankees and
Boston and whatever Cora I don't know
and I was like I was just talking about
this relief so I went to Pete Rose's
page and it's like for information on
how to contact Pete
so I sent an email and see what happens
I sends another one next week what were
you saying I'm sorry that the lands
first-ever like what the way the room
you know there's uh you know the two
oldest ones the one who either live in
color gave me some tips one night they
were very encouraging to me at the
Comedy Store when it was a dark place
and I wasn't a bad time they were the
ones that were like bro that joke is
[ __ ] solid dawg the way you want up
dead dance and you had me crashing haha
you know those Damon right Damon Keenan
those are the ones that were really they
would go up to the hand with Paul yeah
they were booked that'd be with Paul
Mooney at night so we had that and
Keenan kept coming
Keenan wasn't listen bro all right guys
when you get into comedy the good thing
about comedy is you're always gonna end
up somewhere you might not end up a
comic because you like right now I'm
trying to write a book but I've had a
hard time putting my thoughts onto that
paper and that's okay you can't be good
at everything I don't want to change the
oil on the car either okay but some
comedy you're gonna learn way you want
to go Phil Jackson was not the best
basketball player of all time no but he
learned how to be a good coach so Keenan
would struggle on stage you know he
would just go up there you know he's a
funny mind
um it's like if David Chase won on stage
he can't [ __ ] do what he does on The
Sopranos and transfer it to stand up he
knows how to transfer it to his scene he
sees the big picture some people see the
big picture with Kenan you can tell he
saw the big picture he didn't see jokey
poos weren't his forte
he would usually come down with Daymond
and Robert Thompson I think - and Robert
they would meet that girl friends this
is 97-98 what toss that that big trash
go the Hat there you go you want to talk
about farts I'll give you farts
[ __ ] so uh Oh a little backup
there's always a tremor one day one day
a father is always a trembling you know
as far as that we were told done shut up
he's in the last word all right so it's
funny that it would Damon would go up
Kenan will go up and then Damon and what
happened was Kenan went up one night at
the store this is what we used to get 18
people so you had to have four people to
have a show if you went up there and
bomb the tent dirty people gonna walk
we're gonna lose people yeah guys that
would go up at 12 we're being the back
cheering for you don't bomb because bro
it was like it wasn't a [ __ ] welcome
we're gonna [ __ ] leave that's how bad
it was
it's like a budding Abbott time we need
it that's fifteen [ __ ] dollars please
don't walk people so we will go up there
and watch you and Bulldog you if you
went up there and set a bad joke we were
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] you're
gonna walk these people so what happened
was this kept happening people were
going up there bombing and me and a
handful of other guys couldn't go up
I don't Wednesday night because you went
up there with your stupid [ __ ]
magician jokes and everybody [ __ ]
walked so one night Kenan went up there
and he wasn't having a good night
there's eight people and Kenan goes up
and he's not having the best night of
his life
Damon was on after him okay
and we were back there cheering for
Keenan and he's not going in the
direction we wanted to and all sudden
you see two people order a tab they go
tab please and I'm like losing my mind
and the fine I would never disrespect
never would i disrespect another comic
onstage one of my friends Thomas Ward
remember Thomas I reward my brother from
ball throwing in Detroit you can
although him the other brother they're
all killers from Detroit Thomas Ward got
up and yo yo you ain't funny [ __ ] get
off the [ __ ] stay sauce I saw the
young brothers could get stage time and
he meant it like come on man you bump us
and then you're not font tubber's war
thomas [ __ ] ward took it seriously
like I'm in McCallum Thomas next thing
you know what happened to you last night
like man how the brother gonna take
stage time from a [ __ ] brother
you don't fan I'm trying to make my
little 15 [ __ ] dollars they
gotta come in they're playing him it's
any [ __ ] Griffon we had had it by
that time because the lake crew was
getting tortured we already you already
knew of you blowing up at midnight that
Paul Mooney was coming bro you will see
a night where Paul Mooney did two hours
Eddie Griffin did three and then a dice
not closing out with two and a half
brother Eddie Griffin will go up at 9:15
and get off at 11:30 when they give him
the light and tell him Paul was dead I'd
sent him a note then he Paul would go up
then do an hour and a half
Andrew would come up with his cousin and
we just sit there all night we had a spy
but I know but see what I tell people
when this happened don't worry about
unemployment go get your cash and the
supermarket go stock shelves me and
Felipe never had that problem because
Felipe turned me on to all his buddies
moves they paid 50 bucks I paid 50 bucks
50 bucks 50 bucks 50 bucks 50 bucks that
should adds up [ __ ] yeah free burritos
Fox and on the way ever Ralphie going
over there to Ralphie to and I'll go
away home King taco that's what you guys
didn't know that you fed me but on the
way home I made a stop at King tacos
for half to the coke war off you don't
saying you know when the coke is going
down you just got to stuff your face
even though you don't like it at the end
of your coke kindly to really kill your
coke are you gonna eat some but Lee you
don't want to eat nothing I mean they
could bring you the best steak from the
world and you're like I don't want to
eat it
you gotta force yourself to eat it see
could fall asleep so I would take home
that food from taco he taco which
Mexicans would tell me don't go there
but to me they made a chorizo pop my
burrito it's potato and chorizo smother
and green sauce with cheese I would take
that [ __ ] home I'm never putting
the brakes on the car you ever see your
burrito fly off oh yeah I held on to
that burrito like a three-year-old child
dogs I mean it on the floor but my arm
was on the [ __ ] like that thing like a
flop if you ever get the lure I'll jump
or Ltd sorry they're like a little hot
drink they got olia bro yeah they got
good [ __ ] over in King Taco that
security guard there oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] another [ __ ]
Sicario bro those my Chet Oh homie got
everything nice handcuffs a riot helmet
he knows what type of clientele shows up
expert a rally from Tijuana
yeah no no tremendous tremendous I love
that he's 70 years old he's long we all
die you know what man I hope that I hope
that since a lot of people can't travel
or don't want to travel I hope that that
Mexican saying comes back I hope that
the Spanish the young Spanish dudes
start putting those rooms together I
miss them I'm not gonna lie to you but I
also don't want to go get ripped off
either I know that though advertised
Joey Diaz charge $20 and try to give me
15 and you get there and you get blue
you get to the alko poked or restaurant
and Donny and Joe Diaz ain't there yeah
but now I got a show up I'm in those
days I helped I was in the show if
somebody paid me 80 before and you had a
fifty dollar set of ten and I didn't
have a set at the store mmm I already
had eighty you know I'm saying that's
that's a good number 80 that's 64 a gram
ten dollars for two packs of cigarettes
and the other ten for breakfast you know
I'm sayin eighty was the magic number so
if I was in a while I'll be - uh - what
- crazy as [ __ ] joy here's $200 keep it
or other will use it our drugs I had no
choice
dude it's the only way I can stop one
that Phillippi you have broken stocks
and I'm gonna make believe I didn't see
those I have a plantar fasciitis don't
work or you have plantar fasciitis
what's that then the heel of my foot
yeah bursitis
something like that yeah and then the my
my heel was hurting like I have nails
when I got off to bed oh my god would
you go pee in the mall yeah in the
morning so you gotta stay on your feet
when you have that [ __ ] because gonna
call [ __ ] out as soon as you sit down
and you get up you want to shoot you so
at 3:00 and the more I got that from
wearing [ __ ] merengue shoes [ __ ]
Spanish shoes when you were Spanish am
sure those [ __ ] little [ __ ] mames
you where I'm gonna lie to you why are
you because they had no support yeah oh
yeah no I'm like half laugh about that
plunger yeah
I'm like half a fat butt flat foot but I
had that from when I went to prison I
used to run my - you thought I was dirt
and it was fine but once I got the
boulder I ran the trail the cab the
River Trail and that's concrete and I
developed that thing and then from I was
a car salesman so I would wear those
Italian shoes those Italian shoes are
great you can't be on them on your feet
all day being jazz good for a [ __ ]
first communion right you know into
dinner
they ain't good to be on your feet for
ten hours so I got that Plan C follow
the [ __ ] pain did you get the inserts
I got the answers of world if I want to
I went to Rite Aid and there's a foot
machine right there like an electric one
word that measures you so I got it I
didn't give a [ __ ] by that and I say
barefoot and they measure my foot and my
soul and then right away told me what
um what kind of soul to get and I got it
and I've been putting that in my shoe
let me tell you man immediately it's
it's completely different cuz my smile
all right before I was just man with a I
was standing on top of a golf ball for a
while for that pain could go away and it
was man it's going away man did you get
the needle hell no they give you they
give you a needle my brother-in-law
they do two options I've really loved
Lisa's brother he got two they're called
a couple of quotes on Corazon shot he
got two corazon shots one is poor you
know what you get I got one in the left
foot and then I stopped with the
cortisone shots I figured out that it's
funny man when you when I fight when I
finally found out what I what I really
had plantar fasciitis and you talk about
it all summer I'm on my podcast and let
away a lot of my listeners said I have
it too and they hooked me up with a
bunch of different places a couple of
YouTube page but for stretches the foot
store yeah that's what they're doing you
know your feet hurt
let me taste those shoes you wear those
balances yeah why was our perfect place
adidas eyewear yeah they'll kill my feet
I love them they're for stage therefore
the stage they're not to walk around 57
they'll have to walk around if I wear
them a lot I'm done I gotta wear the New
Balance that's all man snake the New
Balance with the extra support when I
went to Columbus to Columbus funny bone
they have a New Balance store right
across street from the hotel well and
that's trip it's New Balances first cuz
it's a California I just cake factor hmm
it's on the same strip and one day I
walked into a new Balance and that dude
he banged me out for $350 but the [ __ ]
he gave me for my feet they never heard
again so when I fly I wear the New
Balances with sweatpants it's got the
inserts already in them I could walk 20
miles like Jesus nothing nothing I'm
saying you know but now my knees hurt a
little bit it's not the same now I'm a
little old
you know now I don't know what the
[ __ ] that happens I don't really want
to push it with the walking sometimes I
walk the next day my heel feels good
sometimes I walk a lot in my heels mal
was dragging my I didn't know what was
going on I would get up to go pee on the
road you know and I didn't know Lee
right and I'm walking hitting the hard
floor in the bathroom and you feel like
I feel like I'm walking on top of golf
balls yeah you have no idea you know I
know Marcy no marbles the first time I
went the doctor wouldn't he shot me in
the foot and I sat there for like six
hours and told my color came back the
pain of that needle because it goes into
the ball they have to shrink that ball
so it's a little boy it's called the
bursar it's a little boy that yeah full
of calcium right little calcium yeah
that buildup
it's a [ __ ] what I don't know what
it's filled to be filled with [ __ ] that
I'm [ __ ] know I just know it hurts
the [ __ ] out of your feet man what would
you do to adjust you know anything are
you happy are you okay with this with a
planter or no no talking about just
what's going on with life right now what
I've been doing to adjust you did you
have you accepted it that they might not
be a road 2.10 I accept that man they
gonna be nothing I know that I'm not
gonna be touring 300 Cedars any more
this year or more than that for a while
I don't think I don't know man like at
first I joked around a body you know
like I'm not gonna open
I'm not gonna go out on the road so I
start seeing more white [ __ ] opening up
like you know like crochet class you
know or Megacon or comic card
conventions and one that will like are
we gonna have another common kind of the
conventions are done they're done
cons are done well I think about the
Otero improv you know whenever you were
selling a show that house how hot that
hallway is where people are waiting to
for the next show to come in that's
gonna say Mike you gotta figure those
things out there's no ventilation there
ventilation there they have to really I
don't want to go to a show
and have somebody hit me up and said a
quart COBIT I wouldn't listen like all
the bad things I've done that I would
feel bad about that I would feel bad
about that somebody came to a show that
listens to the podcast that knows we
take this [ __ ] responsibly if you don't
feel good stale I'd rather you stay home
and tell me you have Colvin
I'll [ __ ] send you a video that's
funny you say that because you know
people make your video a [ __ ] half of
me whacking off with my drums my balls
are the hammer I'll be waiting for you
but I'd rather do that then you come in
and infest a hundred people at a show
that I'm throwing how many sick people
have you seen at your show before though
I seen a lot of sick people at my show I
see more wheelchairs often and the
coffin wheelchairs don't bother me I
mean that that's just I love all those
bad I have nothing against that it's the
people who come in and they're sick you
know we talk about the flu the flu is a
thing that could be cured but here's the
problem with the flu it doesn't really
affect all of us the same way the same
way Kovac does the flu hits you for one
or two days and guess what Lee I'm sorry
to tell you you got bills to pay
you're an American you've got bills to
pay so you want me to stay home all week
because I have the flu for an American
if we could walk around and talked on
the phone we're good enough to go to
work so we go to work we still have the
germs in this and the whole office gets
sick we're doing the right thing as
Americans and stuff like that but as
humans
we'll get other people sick whether it's
the flu or whatever the [ __ ] it is so
that's the problem you have I don't I
don't really really from what I'm saying
it doesn't take a genius I hope nobody's
feelings get hurt but I'm not saying
people being careful I'm not seeing it
you cannot be in a bar and social
distance filipe me and you could start
here yeah yeah you don't really very
good [ __ ] unemployment hasn't come this
week really but after we have three
drinks we're gonna get closer and closer
look I'll hug you people again I miss
hugs
how good people again and the music so
this is what
doesn't sit well with me I don't ever
want somebody to come to an improv show
or any other club whether it's Amy's in
Nashville whether it's a stress factory
in New Jersey and for them to say bro
you know but then this is what people
don't understand right now there's two
words that people don't want to get
through that and it's pay pay cut
hey cut give me the option I know your
room I'm not gonna mention the name of a
club I know your room Felipe I know how
it sits without putting all three other
people in there for my week yeah Joey
but I hate to pay bills it's 200 why
because I don't care about to [ __ ]
extra hundred money I don't want nobody
to get sick I know your room you put
people on top of people in your [ __ ]
room you bring some chairs behind behind
my back how many clothes have you got
until they put people on top of people a
lot a lot and they don't give a [ __ ]
about them people I went to a certain
club I'm not going to say the name he
had people standing up did I get mad at
him yet because I'm not getting paid on
those tickets he's selling those against
my [ __ ] will but if people gonna be
that stupid to stand then yet you know
so this is the things I'm avoiding I
don't want somebody to get sick of my
show yeah I'm saying I'm not gonna go
see nobody until we know what's going on
in you know we got to build our immune
systems believe now we're gonna die so
this is something that you do little by
little how the [ __ ] you gonna be around
me Leif I don't [ __ ] you gonna be around
Lisa sounded Bob Rizzo and rocky and
Wolfie for six months and all someone
put you out I want two hundred seventy
five five hundred and fifty people a
night with different immune systems that
might get you sick right there because
we haven't been around big crowds what
comedians I I know for a fact a lot of
comedians didn't get cold you know why
because we if you travel a lot you have
a tremendous immune system immune system
if you're on a plane three-quarters of
the year your immune system
already up I know people who fly one
time a year they get sick so that tells
me my immune system is up there already
but we got to rebuild it now yeah we've
been keeping it alive we exercise we
take vitamin D we do all that [ __ ] but
have you really built up your immune
system that's why we have to start from
scratch I can't be in an office of 50
people some reason to get Kovac that's
what happened with baseball that's what
happened with the Philadelphia Phillies
too sweet
you put 22 people together eight people
gonna get it we're not even ready that's
why it's gotta be in small amounts small
amounts sure the hope the hospitals are
full we can they got hurt immunity last
week or whatever the [ __ ] they got and
all those protests who gives a [ __ ] I'm
here for my brother Felipe I can't call
it don't work I don't know man they
tried to cancel they shook at circo
Vader
they should cancel everything I know man
my last show I did though what I was
there in Washington my national was the
yakima and you know they had the biggest
the biggest outbreak the big outbreak
was in Kirkland Kirkland which is from
the Tri City and now some people
actually drove from Kirkland to my show
from Richland all that area comma is the
Palm Springs Washington
Yakima Washington shout-out is where
outlet cholos go to retire and now man
it was so great show it was like 12
other people without my last show and um
and I was and I tell Rodrigo we didn't
catch it then we're good bro we were in
Washington and we flew back a little
tiny plane but I haven't flown since and
I'm gonna like the first couple of three
days I was scared I had to cancel my
post Malone show with Lisa I would say I
was gonna take her dirty post Malone for
her birthday and we can so that we can
winning go to Vegas and I still be
taking my acting class on zoom so that
I'm so good talk
you've been taking care of you
the [ __ ] important [ __ ] yeah man
working out drinking water it's trying
to be like me but you know what do you
noticed you about everybody I don't know
how they most of America but I'm gonna
tell up my neighborhood I walk my dog
every day at 7:00 in the morning and
welcome every day at 6:00 p.m. my
neighborhood in a ghost town bro and no
one ever outside I mean it's a [ __ ]
ghost town when we walk alone nobody I
never see anybody I never seen no one
but there's houses all around me since
the pandemic I've seen fathers and
daughters riding bikes together I've
seen mom's walking with her dog and
their son I've seen more family time
together I think when these kids
literally run think about it what
they're gonna miss most about this time
is all that closeness you have with your
family but Allah I'm pretty sure there's
a lot of domestic violence too but a lot
of people like you got to know your
father for the first time you got to see
your father at home you know my father
was always at work I never got to see my
dad I mean I'm pretty sure like a lot of
people are getting to know their father
are pretty sure it's tough with a lot of
dads out there they got a racer kids
finally yes while the parents had to
raise their kids because the nannies
wouldn't commit I listen for me like
I've repeated this I can't say it enough
we've gotten tighter over there we
celebrate our 20-year anniversary July
first and we've been we can't wait we
can't [ __ ] believe it that we've been
together for 20 years so we've been
getting tighter over there it's a
different type of times when you have a
cat the first three years you're like
[ __ ] this dad has been great this cats a
lot of fun but once you have a cat seven
eight years it become something else he
knows when you're having a bad day he
knows when you need them I had a cat
that knew when I was gonna pass out and
he'd jump on me and claw me so I would
focus on the claws I wouldn't pass out
you know it's the same thing with women
you know it's the same thing with fur
we've been around each other though you
know I've been sitting here with you for
an hour and I've had you know five
people have called from Mars Jobrani you
know just checking up on me you know we
have friends we have family so it makes
this a lot easier I've tried to be Lee's
family during this you know Steve Simone
I look after all the single guys yeah I
check up on this old comic that I work
with up north he lives by himself we've
been doing stand-ups in 1970 something's
very funny guy Larry bubbles Brown okay
Marv Marv
let's do this [ __ ] hilarious and then
there's another older guy named mom I
know no I only call my sister I check up
an army you know when is your special
coming out at the end of my opponent
come on in the fall okay we don't know
it we don't have a date I both of them
coming out together yes together it's
gonna be like Guns and Roses so the
rules say you're illusioned 1 & 2 really
use your it's gonna be like that
Felipe's bought both of them are coming
on the same yeah but they're gonna be
separated like learn to be together one
special one wanna being they want to be
Spanish that's [ __ ] phenomenal you
know a man I and I work hard man I know
yeah I I did a I did a couple of Spanish
shows at The Comedy Store and of course
you wanna for a while yeah I was gonna I
was gonna Tijuana Mexico once a month
for a year with Rodrigo and March and
Rizzo when you went and did the special
with a lot of white people in your
audience yes we're at at the Spanish
special though they showed up and they
left that's what I was scared of with
yeah people need to see that but in the
beginning people didn't know I was gonna
be in Spanish so they will show up so
what I did was I found out um at the the
comedy palace you have been there yeah
yeah another place I used to go there to
eat that place paid $200 150 bucks and
fed you Kairo
now the first time I've ever had a gyro
Brewer had goat meat that's right yeah
man they then when I when I did it they
used to put on a cup I don't call the
Greek palace the Greek palace
and then the kid took it off yeah and
then they still sold gyros but they
would pay you from the bucket and you
have to stay outside after the show and
stand there I had already done the
Longest Yard but I needed the money for
cocaine so I would they offer me a
giggling I gave me like a sort of a
guarantee but if we make more I'll give
you more and I did good but I remember
that was the hardest money Abbot oh yeah
money out of a bucket that people put in
a bucket that's hard money to take
that's embarrassment money but the
addiction made me take it that's the
last time I then the guy that used to
run it got a TV show and he got some
reality show and he [ __ ] reached out
to me like to reuse it relate it coming
audition for a go [ __ ] yourself well I
got 20 years go [ __ ] your mother but
come audition if you give it to me and
not into some stupid [ __ ] reality
show
Filippo we've done a lot of gigs
together brush [ __ ] lord ma'am god damn
Felipe night you reached right out to me
when I came we gravitated right to one
another and [ __ ] Willy used to piss I
was your search though we made it out
the Laugh Factory the Laugh Factory on
Monday night I still think about Marilyn
I still think about all those times I
tell [ __ ] I tell leak that's Selena hit
those guys up that's where you learned
to do cow me in this town it's not in
the open mics it's not in the comedy
clubs it's at those [ __ ] Orange
County sandwich shops that's where you
learned to become that's George Perez
that one shop that was tremendous George
Perez had a great shot listen Sebastian
Cetina ran some great local folk albums
Acapulco rooms Casa latina yeah the rest
will go outside the restaurant chains
you have any [ __ ] that one on Sunset
that's the one now what's the name of it
now there's such a room Sycamore tavern
was the original a couple
that's my back yeah right there on
sunset yeah when I first start doing
holiday come on I want is there yeah all
my friends they did follow Jake's bro
and then they have one in Super
Wednesday night so you stay on sunset ah
and you go about that towards the
[ __ ] Scientology building right then
you make that you see the movie theater
on the corner and you make that left in
that right in the Silver Lake ah 50
yards that was not the pool go so we
used to hit the or you could eat your
you could eat lunch or that food those
Appa dog or you could even like the
cheese enchiladas we went there with a
Mexican rice and the soup and [ __ ] with
the chips and the all you could drink
iced tea we went through many a heater
oh that's the first place I ate dinner
and when I moved from Seattle me and the
girls really on Sunset then we went to
Fairfax and took a shower in the [ __ ]
trailer and we ended up going to the
comedy store then back to Doug Stanhope
south and we parked in front of Doug
Stanhope silence with the trailer that's
the first dinner I had in that way when
I became when I came into LA January 27
1997 I pulled up at 7 o'clock
we've made it to rush out we exited
Hollywood Highland and we said where's
the Comedy Store that's tonight that was
it where's the Comedy Store
she looked it up in the Thomas guide we
went that we said the Comedy Store still
not open till 8 o'clock we said [ __ ] it
let's go alkyl poco when we took showers
there was a shower that spit out like
three pounds from a minute it was
garbage it was like a drain in the
common story no in the [ __ ] RV we had
oh when I drove from LA we drove from
Seattle I drove it in our Levite with a
car behind us and the [ __ ] shower you
got to fill it up with a hose the thing
and then they were filled up and then
you had them like three minutes to take
a shower with medium water spittin a and
we took a shower and went over to the
comedy store so as i walked in i saw
Eddie Griffin
and the black guy from the black dragon
you know the guy that played - what yeah
the star
I went inside I went onstage who was
onstage dombarris donning the open mic
right went outside I saw wheels Parisi
and I remember him opening up Fran you
Dice Clay and I almost lost my [ __ ]
mind wheels poori she so just think
about that I open for real / Rishi's and
consul Bluff Iowa remember that casino
gig yes and the cool man wheel has game
bro
for a big guy I've heard one mm he oh he
loved AG women and he hooked up with a
front death chamber all he told her he
was another promise you that boy tell
you he'll go and get the lighter hey you
let that boy tell your story I'm in
warned my hands will talk good story
though well tell you he was in
Goodfellas what scene were you and you
know the one with her on a career though
you know he wasn't even in the [ __ ]
what neighborhood when the were
Yellowjackets you know he says he was on
Letterman they've threatened them to
find the tape it's out there it's out
there those are the best times in my
life having conversation with him cuz we
were just yeah part of pop culture
Goodfellas almond goodies in The
Godfather he's in he was at the wedding
scene and Godfather
he's got more stories than the boys I've
been in more movies just nobody has seen
his role they just skip over the movies
I've never seen anything like that my
life I'm happy you came in for a nice
little Monday chat you made me feel good
if I felt the little robots especially
after the rough weekend with these
people and stuff like this listen at
this point I don't give a [ __ ] about
what happens we still run the podcast
that's a church walk game we got the
church right and that's all you need and
I'll be back on the road I didn't know
anything about [ __ ] movies a film if
I offended anybody from The Sopranos I'm
sorry if they don't want to use me or
whatever if I offended you know anybody
else whatever what can I tell you this
is what we do here we when you watch a
movie from the 70s you know why they're
so good because they disturbed
The Exorcist disturbed yeah man The
Godfather disturbed you the [ __ ] to
get away when Steve McQueen beats out
his wife it described you all these
things disturbed you but it took you
somewhere and opened up a different door
in your mind when I come here and I
[ __ ] spell harder more Russell
speedier yeah when I come here and spew
my [ __ ] I must be you in a hate or they
think I'm just ruin my life and the
mistakes I made so you guys know what
direction you could take your life I
mean look at look at Animal House they
had a girl they were making out she
ended up being in high school like in a
different time that story you told that
got you in trouble could be like the
opening scene to your movie and people
loved it
[ __ ] you're not gonna please
everybody all the time
but you know what you could be yourself
you wanna penalize him for me being me
dad I don't give a [ __ ] you're not going
nowhere
these people aren't buying it neither on
me so it's over you know why cuz we
cancelled it I don't give a [ __ ] and can
intimidate me not now now I did my time
I did my time and I'm gonna get what I
got I'm gonna get right that's this
isn't Goodfellas I did my time I got
mouths to feed
I did my I did what I was supposed to do
for this country I was a felon I did my
time I came out and I took my life in a
different direction
did I make mistakes along that way yes I
did but I still got to where I'm going
and the message is still loud and clear
I don't give a [ __ ] if you think you're
[ __ ] you could do what the [ __ ]
we're doing with no geniuses these
actors you see then though geniuses
they're insecure retards just like me
I'm an insecure [ __ ] but we put
something together so if I could do it
with no family no mother no father no
education can you imagine what these
people could do with everything they got
I don't have what most people have so if
we could do it you got to go for it
we're both [ __ ] it listen man a lot
of people say oh so I'm gonna use drugs
I'm gonna do all this to make it more
you're lucky you don't have to go to
none of that you not to go to another
he's telling you these things so you
won't go
through that so [ __ ] you but you wanna
do it I said to you [ __ ] [ __ ]
what's your next day promote you to a
mafia July third fourth and fifth San
Antonio Texas July 16 17 18
Houston improv over there with
what's-his-name the same people there
Houston improv man man if they would
have seen the [ __ ] we dinner that at the
last stop they will put us in jail one
of the best owners oh man he was gonna
be the real nice guy I love people and I
an MP brought that one yeah that young
kid didn't speak no Spanish and by the
time we closed he spoke better English
and most beep damn it David David
I still miss David and lost his number
somewhere along the line we got
disconnected murmur it's cuz it with a
horrible weed it's cause that good coke
yeah horrible we but that muhfucka
ethnic cartel coke that should've
maintained at that I did not know that
dude always have Nate ball for me as
soon as I landed all I have to do is get
to the Kaaba call them the night before
you know I'm coming they using tomorrow
dog gets in my jaw boom I will get to
the hotel call the club tell the older
than I have the draw ready for me I'm
gonna need it because I got my sneakers
there was no sneakers I was buying the
[ __ ] biggest rock to cook there
wasn't he isn't it that night so we
lived a long life Philippe him was still
here to tell the stories was still torn
there's guys are coming gone that were
[ __ ] gonna take over the world the
world they tell a they're [ __ ] lost a
lot over here so thank you for coming
here on a Monday more than podcast don't
forget to listen to Felipe's podcast so
what's our full podcast right I wore the
sweatshirt awesome watch me on had to
find a Netflix
really I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm I knows I
have a Korean role on a show on Netflix
identified and to fight I play a guy
named mom crazy Dave okay and we just
got asked to do a sexy
- you're [ __ ] beautiful brother so
I'm talking about
do you remember I was asking Rodrigo
remember we do acting classes of your
porch now you know you Rick Ramos today
you'll be totally and number three go
when you really want to do it you
[ __ ] do it we didn't have money for
an acting class so we were doing the
scenes from Donnie Donnie Brasco where
the scene where his son is in the
hospital for a heroin overdose and we're
doing the semen we share yeah and you
were trying to be like and with the
scene were so he able to do smack him in
the face yeah and he respond was I got
blisters or I got I got my knuckles I
have calluses or some we did that scene
and we also did the scene from Carlito's
Way yeah when he goes to visit the guy
in jail I got the hole dug I got the
lime ready I got the shovels all I need
is the [ __ ] word and you go in that
[ __ ] hole
you understand me but mister whatever I
never stole your money shut the [ __ ] up
I do a little I do a lot of business
with Jews but I never liked you sorry
client and we always talk about that
that I remember that day when we were
doing that scene we got high and we
ended up talking about how badass that
one white actor came in playing that
Puerto Rican come on man what was the
movie Oh Carlito's Way they know oh yeah
give me a [ __ ] wheelchair bro
kill that see you gotta won the Academy
Award yeah a Sebastian green book yeah
he played a puerto rican in the black
the white guy all the white guy what's
his name the white dude that played that
movie and guestbook and he came on the
american way to animate down drunk he's
done but do that movie seen that scene
with any thousand what impressed me was
he asked him if he wanted old bosses
don't bother
that's a word that people will never
have a use again that means a bump in
cuban get on posset
so when he said that his name is on the
tip of my tongue
and I can veto Morgan's we don't
Morgenson veto morgenson veto Morgan
simple evolution we came in the
wheelchair you guys drunk out all dirty
that was it were you talking about how
good that was nobody even mentioned his
[ __ ] name come on man you got
everything a [ __ ] pie I can't even
[ __ ] no more and then Luiz Guzman cuz
then I'm gonna [ __ ] shoot you shoot
me I shoot me you miserable [ __ ] you're
a bad [ __ ] you got a website and
a website Felipa the worldcom I love you
don't let it take you lose me first of
all thank you for supporting me thank
you for the kind words you were on the
internet about me Friday night and I
want to thank you for coming on the show
and not being part of the [ __ ]
canceled community that [ __ ] [ __ ] is
done the cancer culture is done amongst
comics you [ __ ] [ __ ] have done
enough the [ __ ] try to be cute and if
you don't like the [ __ ] show switch
the [ __ ] channel that's it
[ __ ] it's over so I want to
thank Felipe Esparza I want to thank the
[ __ ] and most importantly I
want to thank you guys don't forget
we're also on Spotify Spotify YouTube
iTunes we don't only know the next few
weeks things are gonna be happening but
we'll keep you posted you know I'm
saying so I love you guys have a great
week uncle Joey [ __ ] adores you
[ __ ] thank you for having my
back
we set a president today I'm [ __ ]
Twitter we set a president by letting
people know they just can't cancer you
because that you're not that cup of tea
[ __ ] you switch the channel [ __ ] leak
kick this [ __ ] meal
[Music]